On November 14, 1971, NASA’s Mariner 9 probe, entered orbit around Mars, becoming the first spacecraft to orbit another planet.
Its mission? Mainly, to take lots of pictures
and map out the Martian surface.
But mission engineers found themselves facing
a challenge that they’d never faced before on Earth.
On our planet, we talk about altitude in terms
of sea level.
The highest point on Earth, for example, is at the top of Mount Everest, which is 8,850 meters above sea level.
But Mars doesn’t have a sea.
So the mission team had to pick something
else to use as a reference point.
They chose the point where Mars’s atmospheric pressure was 6.105 millibars -- the minimum pressure that liquid water needs to exist.
That’s right -- at very low pressures, liquid water just isn’t a thing, no matter the temperature.
Why not?
The answer lies in phase changes: what happens when molecules don’t quite live up to what we’d predict for an ideal gas.
[Theme Music]
We’ve talked before about temperature,
and how it’s a measure of the kinetic energy
-- the energy of motion -- of a substance.
And we know that as temperature increases, so does kinetic energy, because of the kinetic theory of gases, which describes how ideal gas molecules behave.
As you might remember from our last episode, a gas is considered ideal, if it fits a few basic assumptions:
First, that the total volume of the gas molecules
is much less than the volume of the container they’re in.
Second, that these molecules only interact
with each other when they collide.
And last, that the collisions are perfectly
elastic, meaning that no energy is lost.
The kinetic theory of gases is based on the idea that if you have all these gas molecules bouncing around, you can calculate the average kinetic energy of each particle.
We’ve already talked about how, in general, the kinetic energy of an object is equal to half of its mass x its velocity squared.
And the average kinetic energy of the ideal gas molecules in a container, is equal to half of a molecule’s mass x the average squared velocity of the molecules.
And if you do the math, this average kinetic energy also turns out to be equal to 3/2 x a set constant k x the temperature.
k is just equal to the constant R we talked about last time, divided by Avogadro’s number, 6.02 x 10^23, the number of molecules in a mole.
This equation might not look like much, but it’s important because it tells you exactly how kinetic energy and temperature are related in an ideal gas
As the kinetic energy of the gas increases,
temperature increases proportionally.
We already knew that - but now we’ve done what we often have to do in physics which is back up our assumptions using math.
Now, you may have noticed something a little unusual about the way we’ve been representing the velocity of these ideal gas molecules.
We’ve been talking about their velocities
in terms of averages, which makes sense,
since we’re trying to describe the overall behavior
of all the molecules, not individual ones.
To get the average kinetic energy, we didn’t
just take the average velocity and square it.
Instead, we squared all the individual velocities, then used the average of those squared values.
This whole average-squared-velocity thing, helps our math work out, and it’s important to remember when you’re analyzing an ideal gas.
The square root of the average squared velocity
is what we call the root mean square speed.
We write it as v_RMS, and it’s a different
number from the average speed.
Say you know that a gas’s temperature is 300 Kelvin, and the mass of each molecule is 5.3 x 10^-26 kilograms.
And you want to find the speed of a typical
molecule.
Well, we have an equation for that!
Half the mass x the average squared velocity
is equal to 3/2 x k x the temperature.
So, to get the typical speed of a gas molecule,
you’re going to want to find
the square root of the average squared velocity, which
is equal to the square root of 3 x k x the temperature divided by the mass.
In this case, that works out to 484 m/s.
But 484 m/s isn’t the average speed -- it’s
the root mean square speed.
So, how does the root mean square speed compare
to the actual speeds of the molecules in the gas?
Well, back in 1859, Scottish physicist James Clerk Maxwell used statistical analysis to figure out the distribution of speeds in an ideal gas.
And it looks like this.
The top of the curve shows the speed that’s
close to the speed of the greatest number of molecules.
And the root mean square speed is slightly
to the right of that.
So the molecules in an ideal gas can actually
have a whole range of different speeds.
But most of them are pretty close to
the root mean square speed,
so it’s a useful way to get a picture of
how fast a gas’s molecules are moving.
Now, we’ve seen the smooth, even way pressure
and volume change with temperature in an ideal gas.
But gases aren’t always ideal.
When the pressure gets too high, or the temperature
too low, they start to act very strange.
High pressure is a problem, because it forces molecules together to the point where they start to interact.
Low temperature is an issue for similar reasons.
The molecules have less kinetic energy -- they’re
moving around less energetically --
so their attraction to each other starts to have an effect.
And, remember, we said that one of our assumptions about ideal gases was that they don't have forces acting between molecules.
They just bounce off of each other like ping
pong balls.
So, at higher pressures and lower temperatures, real gases tend to have a bit less volume than ideal gases would.
And at really high pressures and really low
temperatures, gases just start acting weird.
And then eventually they aren’t even gases
anymore.
At a certain point, the attraction between the molecules takes over and stops them from bouncing around so much.
They become slightly more ordered, and take
the form that we call a liquid.
Like when water vapor from the air condenses on the outside of your nice cool glass of orange juice, kind of making it look like it’s sweating.
Increase the pressure or lower the temperature even more, and the attraction between the molecules has even more of an effect.
The liquid freezes into a solid.
In the same way, lowering a solid’s pressure or raising its temperature will eventually make it melt into a liquid and then boil into a gas.
Well … usually.
Take a look at this diagram.
It shows the different phases of water depending
on its pressure and temperature.
The vertical axis shows pressure, so the higher
up you go in the diagram, the more pressure there is.
The horizontal axis shows temperature, so the farther you are to the right, the higher the temperature.
Below the diagonal line (so, at low pressures
and high temperatures) water takes the form of
water vapor: a gas.
To the left of the line that’s nearly vertical,
water is ice: a solid.
And at the pressures and temperatures represented
by the triangle in the middle, water is a liquid.
But you’ll notice that there’s a point
toward the top right labeled the critical point.
On a phase diagram, the critical point represents the maximum temperature and pressure where the substance can be a liquid.
For a gas to become a liquid, it has to be below a certain temperature known as the critical temperature.
For water, the critical temperature is about
647 Kelvin.
Above the critical temperature, you can increase the pressure as much as you want, but the gas will never condense into a liquid.
There’s a critical pressure, too, which
for water is about 22 megapascals.
If the pressure is above the critical pressure, you can raise the temperature as much as you want, but the liquid will never boil.
Then there’s the point toward the bottom
left, where the two lines intersect.
That’s the triple point.
And that's what Mariner 9 used to map out Mars!
A triple point is the temperature and pressure at which a substance coexists as a solid, a liquid, and a gas.
It’s also what we use to define the Kelvin
temperature scale.
The triple point of water is 6.105 millibars
and exactly 273.16 Kelvin.
That pressure and temperature is special, because at thermal equilibrium, water can exist in three phases at once -- ice, liquid, and vapor.
Now, you’ll notice on the diagram that at pressures and temperatures below the triple point, there’s only the gas phase and the solid phase.
That’s because below its triple point, a
substance can’t actually take a liquid form.
Instead, it’s either a gas or a solid -- and
it transitions directly from one to the other,
a process that’s known as sublimation if it goes from solid to gas, and as deposition if it goes from gas to solid.
That’s why dry ice, which is made of carbon
dioxide, vaporizes directly to gas.
The triple point of carbon dioxide is about 5 times atmospheric pressure, so liquid carbon dioxide can’t naturally exist on Earth.
The triple point of water is used to define
the Kelvin temperature scale because it’s consistent:
You just find the temperature
where you get three phases of water at once
-- which scientists have set to be 273.16
Kelvin by definition.
It also made a lot of sense for the Mariner 9 mission to use the pressure of the triple point of water as the reference point for its Martian maps.
One of our main goals in exploring Mars has always been to search for evidence of life, either now or in the past.
And as far as we know, life needs liquid water.
Since the reference point for Martian altitudes
was the triple point of water, liquid water
couldn't exist at altitudes above the reference
point, where the pressure would be too low.
That made it easy to see on a map all the
places where liquid water could be --
or have been -- and where life could possibly survive,
or have survived.
Today, you learned about the kinetic theory
of gases, and how to calculate the root mean square speed.
We also talked about phase changes, including the critical point, the triple point, and how that all applies on Mars.
Crash Course Physics is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel and check out a playlist of the latest episodes from shows like
PBS Idea Channel, Brain Craft, and Shank's FX.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these amazing people and
our equally amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.